what we call them the research function
and they're based in our office in
Warsaw mhm so their job is to
essentially Source candidates it's
Market mapping building out those
different networks that we kind of head
hunt from within because we don't use
job boards or most don't use job boards
don't use job boards as entry level
Talent really no job boards yeah so we
operate like a executive search type of
company you know we're Market mapping
building out that graduate Network every
year so we have multiple different
networks we've got you know your bog
standard graduate Network and then got
the bilingual Network CU we a lot of the
SDR hires that we do speak a second
language like for the German market
French market Etc I mean it's such a
like incredible function that we have
like I don't know how I used to operate
without a function like that